style is so cool thank you thank you
always I feel like every time I see you
or John Legend y'all look so good thank
you that's my brother I love yeah you
always I know you all do glare together
but I just every time I see either one
of you I'm always like I should really
work on my game like my threads I'm like
oh no I just wear what people put me on
no people people like see me out and
sometimes be like is that John Legend
I'm like no oh I don't think y'all look
anything alike I me I me just how nice
y'all look all the time you always look
so like together and daer it's nice yeah
apprciate how is your 2024 it's
beautiful I'm like like I came in with a
positive mindset in 2024 2023 was kind
of difficult in certain ways and um 2024
I came in with the right with a clear
mind I like I like bringing in the New
Year if I can like either in church or
somewhere like in a in a solid place of
solitude with just my focus and
intentions yeah oh loved
it um so I I heard that your your
daughter just graduated is it law school
yes you raised him well yeah I'm like oh
law school that's a minute she was there
for a minute she was there for a minute
now beautiful her name is a moer and she
you must be so proud I'm super proud and
it's like she went to Howard School um
Howard University historical black
college went to Howard law and now is
working at a firm doing well you know
it's tough but she's doing well and it's
well for me too I don't have any I don't
have to pay any tuition no rent she's
good that's amazing yeah and if you have
any questions yeah exactly can answer I
definitely will put her on the team at
some point you know I'm I'm I'm one of
those people like I'm I'm I'm a tough
dad though I'm like you got to earn your
spot of course I'm going to help her out
and get her to places but I think that's
worth though yeah yeah I want that's oh
my kids all the time are like well we
could just buy it and I go I could you
have no money see that that that you are
poor that is good that is good parenting
to me that's good parenting no because
you got to work for my daughter right
now at nine wants to work she's like can
I at least babysit can I she wants to
I've instilled in her like like I take
her to Target you're spending your
Christmas money I buy you enough I'm
like yeah you got a load of stuff I buy
you you can buy this Kelly I I rock with
I like that like that that will get that
will get our children out there and they
won't feel entitled you have to earn
these things and and also my mother made
me do that because it taught me to value
things I was able to Value like cuz it's
you know as a kid one point as a kid I
was she bought me a pair of drums a set
of drums cuz I said I wanted to be a
drummer I was drumming and after a few
weeks I busted a hole in the drums and
turned it into a basketball hoop like
and she like yo you don't even value
what you got like and I had to learn the
lessons eventually I wish I could drum
now it but at least I'm a good
basketball thing I can't yeah I'm
neither one I can't play basketball or
keep a be you got challeng you got a lot
of chall not that um you we were both
actually raised by single parents um I
was for several years of my life and now
I am one like what what was your
experience with that because it's so
hard I
mean w watching my mom when I was
younger was one thing you're the kid
right but then becoming a single parent
is like a whole other level of
understanding your parent well I have a
I have a lot of reverence and love and
respect from my mother to what she
brought to me as a single mother early
on in my life she implanted so many
strong values in me and just gave me the
love like a full love where I didn't
know what what I was missing and then
she I have to give it up my stepfather
his name is Ralph when she remarried she
married a good man he was a man of he is
a man of good values and a strong human
being and they both had believe in God
so all that like was seeds those were
seeds they planted so look I wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for the love of my
mother and and the work that Ralph put
into me and all my elders and loved ones
once yeah it's definitely a village I
yeah yeah he said a new book called and
then we rise a guide to loving and
taking care of self so the title was
influenced by myangelo right yes yes Dr
myangelo was one of my Inspirations in
life when I was in fth grade she was the
first writer I could remember like
loving her poems and her writing and um
and you know when I was writing this
book I was really thinking
about I I entitled it and then we rise
because I'm a Believer in like the more
we love ourselves the higher we get
within ourselves from the mind the body
the soul um the the higher We rise
within ourselves the better we do for
our communities meaning you know without
self-love you can't really give to give
love as as as well as you should be able
to and I believe that we all deserve joy
and happiness and wellness and I just
wanted to I wanted to write this book as
like a practical guide and and it's not
it's really easy to read it's it's like
me sharing the things that I've
experienced as far as like the chef that
I worked with just some recipes is in
the book yeah um workouts um today I
worked out I didn't feel like working
out but I just did it because I needed
it's part of my practice how do we work
through some of the fears the hurts that
we have I've used obviously um phys I've
used therapy like I work with a
therapist like I work with a therapist
and I've used meditation I've used
prayer my spirituality and I just want
people to have something that that they
find for themselves that will really
serve them so that we can be the best
the best version of ourselves and be in
joy I I Believe In Joy yeah me too I AB
something funny though so when you told
your mom who loves to cook Soulful food
like soul food like that you were GNA be
a vegan how'd that go over how was she
like wait what well first of all she was
like what are you talking about like
when I didn't want to eat the the turkey
at Thanksgiving yeah and and the foods
that that I normally ate they were like
in shock she was kind of like she felt
like I rejected her and I understand cuz
that was her way of giving love you know
like my son is coming home I'm working
all she spent a minute on that turkey
she spent a minute on that she cook the
greens but once she saw I was for Real
about it you know the next year the next
year then it was like okay I got to
start cooking some vegetarian food for
this guy and she she did it and it
wasn't that good at first you know yeah
but now that's like me trying to bake
with all the like healthy sugars I'm
like yeah you got to learn how to you
got to learn how to still the chemistry
of that yeah now let me say because I
know my mother's watching she has
improved and and and and she is a she is
a very good she's a she's a very is
going to whoop your ass she's a very she
is like I have improved okay she's good
she's really good now do you cook do you
like cooking no I I don't cook at all
like I mean I don't think you could be
judging other people's skills anyway
know what taste good you know I'm like
look I was like you know what this
tastes like I didn't cook it so I'll put
it in my mouth I was like are you a good
Chef no no um but you you mentioned
working out and I think um in your the
first film you did is when you really
started getting fit so like what's on
your like workout playlist you got a
playlist my playlist which I put in the
I have a playlist in the book um it's
it's hip-hop it's hip-hop it's like for
me it's '90s hip-hop cuz that's what
that's what that gave me the90s music in
general like '90s music '90s R&B too but
like for me is like like baby face all
over the place but I can't work out the
baby no no but I mean like he like you
know there's he's such a great producer
there's all those songs he like either
produced or singing bgb he's doing all
of it yeah yeah but I I I love working
out to like groups like Tribe Called
Quest and de soul and MOB deep and Pete
Rock and SE smooth like this is music
that just get me going and uh yeah and
and I I never workout to my own songs oh
my God it's so funny people tell me all
the time they're like oh my God you're
my workout playlist I'm like I wish I
worked out to it I know exactly only
time I work out to my music is on stage
when I'm huffing and puffing going you
should probably work out more yeah um so
we we want to also talk about so you're
launching like a social campaign also
with the book right yes it's called make
one change like one of my changes I love
these turmeric lattes oh me too you like
them yes yes I love turmeric I love T
it's good it's really great for you it's
good for especially if you mix it with
black pepper oh I I haven't tried that I
got get very sciency sometimes with
things but yeah yeah so it apparently
opens yes but here's the thing I'm not
so good at retaining so I have other
people friends go read this with me and
then they retain it and then I reminded
yeah listen I'm not mad at you I have
selective memory I'm not I love reading
but I have to say like some of the
things that I've learned come from from
in teachers people that have experienced
it and and just like a lot of the people
in my book like I just I just learn from
them I just listen and and learned so I
get what you're saying about I love yeah
I love learning One Way We rise on our
show is through connection so we thought
we'd do a new segment where we share our
takes on the most controversial topics
from past episodes to see if we come to
a consensus on any this
is okay
run all right Jesse with the runs okay
so all we do is hit this button and our
super computer because it's totally
linked up to a computer we'll look back
through five seasons of shows to find
our most controversial subjects um or
topics rather then we're going to try to
settle things um on each top we're going
to we're going to settle right here are
you ready okay I'm ready to all right
boom well don't be ready to settle
that's not a way to
live o can okay okay this is this one
came up from John CER and I was talking
to him and can you be friends with an ex
yes I could definitely be friends with
an ex I mean like how long was the
relationship um I mean I've been friends
with a lot of exes that I've had and
they've been long relationships cuz most
of them in pretty good I mean we we we
go through stuff at the beginning of the
breakup but then once we come to our
grounds it's like we both we we we good
people we cool people are you friends
with any of your exes
no I mean here's the thing ain't no
judgment no Jud I'm not I'm not not
friends but I feel cuz I'm cool with I I
only have a couple that I'm just like
hard past but but no but you know a
couple of them though I don't have many
exes but like a couple of them are cool
people there nothing wrong with them
there's if we ran into each other we' be
totally friendly invited if they invited
you to a party with like like they said
man we having a a party for some of yeah
depending on the ex yeah no I would be
like okay cool yeah I'll show up like I
can I just feel like like it can get
awkward for it depends on who ended it
or who it is and it it's situational
yeah yeah yeah but for mostly no no I
feel like that's awkward no Common
Ground there here we
go smoking like a Sho CH I'm just being
real oh this is interesting Brie Larson
she brought this one up because she they
like hot dogs she and a friend so wait
it's whether a hot dog is a sandwich I
know you're from Chicago hot dogs are a
big thing there
I'm just saying it's meat and bread it's
not a sandwich it's it's called a hot
dog for Reon I love a hot dog it's a hot
dog I love I eat veggie dogs now and I
love vegg do love I ain't never had a
veggie dog it doesn't sound sexy but we
got some good ones okay okay maybe I
would try it so is a hot dog a sandwich
to you I mean here's the thing I never
thought about it until she said it and
then I was like well why bread and meat
and if bread surrounds the meat that
kind of sounds like a sandwich no no no
I mean why why wouldn't they just call
it a sandwich then I don't know you
might be right on that one I don't know
a pork they would say a pork link
sandwich or something pork link sandwich
oo I love a sausage roll oh no no no I'm
so hungry right
now no Common Ground there here we
[Music]
go okay oh this is a hard one wait who
should be considered greatest rapper of
all time that who answers that other
than common who should I'mma answer I
say common I'mma say I'mma say me I say
common hey hey I'm on my hey that my
answer I'm on
my I'm on my U I'm on my I'm on my nie
Nash my niece I'm going give myself some
than and some love so she she you know
at the enage she gave herself some love
I'm going say I'm the greatest rapper of
all time now if I take myself out of
that conversation then it's for me is
it's not
Rock
Kim Big Daddy Kane
krs1 I know I you um so okay so we we
have common ground on that one I feel
like um comments book is called and then
we rise pick up a copy
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home